hello grammarians welcome to the english
parts of speech we're going to begin
with the noun the lovely wonderful noun
your friend and mine they're mostly what
you're going to encounter in sentences
most sentences in english contain at
least one noun or a pronoun but we'll
get to pronouns later
a noun
is basically anything
and i know that's not an especially
helpful
definition but we'll get more more
specific in a minute and that is
basically anything at all
now the way this is taught in
traditional grammar is to say that a
noun is a person place or thing
which is fine i think we can
make that a little bit sharper and
expand that out by saying that they are
that nouns are
people or living things
places
things
or ideas
i think ideas is the one that usually
gets left out so nouns can be people
places things and ideas
let's put that in action
so this is raul
he's from argentina
he is a penguin
raul has big dreams
now okay so i want to take these three
sentences and find the nouns in them
using the test so the test is is it a
person
or a living thing
a place
a thing
or an idea
and if it's any of those things then it
falls into the category of words in
english which we call nouns so
sentence number one this is raoul
what is raul well raul is a person or a
living thing so we're just gonna say
person so
noun
next sentence he is from argentina
now argentina happens to be a place so
therefore it is also a noun it's a kind
of noun called the proper noun just like
raul is but we'll get to that later so
argentina is a noun argentina
incidentally is a country
and the word country
is also a noun because it is
a thing
so since the third he is a penguin
now penguin is a living
living being or a thing so we can say oh
yes penguin that is a noun
as well so you've noticed i'm not
circling he
or this
um these words are are pronouns or
relative pronouns and they're
they can sometimes behave like nouns but
i wouldn't i wouldn't call them nouns
that'll just get confusing so these are
these are pronouns and we'll get to them
later
sentence number four raul has big dreams
so here we have raul again we know from
the first sentence that it's a person's
name
so we're just gonna say this is also a
noun again and dreams now dream isn't a
person a place it's not it's it's a
thing sure
um the reason i put in idea as a fourth
category is to get it stuff that you
can't you can't pick up like for example
the war so dream yes dream is a noun
um
dream is maybe a little tangible because
it's something you can imagine
but the idea of like a word like bigness
or if you prefer you know size
the the size of of raul's plumage was
astonishing look at that gorgeous
plumage
it's a little penguin mohawk
the size of raul's plumage was
astounding now in that sentence size is
a noun but it's not
it's not a it's not a physical thing
it's not a person it's not a place it's
not something you can
pick up it's an idea so that's why i
include this fourth category so
if you're trying to figure out whether
or not a word is a noun just apply this
test
ask yourself is it a person
a place
a thing
or an idea
and you my friend will be golden
you can learn anything
dave it out